or at this point we have tested more
than 39 million Americans among those
more than 3 million Americans have
tested positive and more than 1.3
million Americans have recovered sadly
more than 133,000 Americans have lost
their lives and our sympathies are with
all of the impacted families and while
we mourn with those who mourn because of
what the American people have done
because the extraordinary work of our
health care workers around the country
we are encouraged that the average
fatality rate continues to be low and
steady and it days earlier this week was
actually 90 percent lower than at the
height of this pandemic again it's a
credit to the sacrifices the American
people have made that the extraordinary
work that our health care workers are
doing and and we pledge this task force
working in partnership with governor's
all across the country is going to
continue to work our hearts out 24 hours
a day to continue to keep our losses low
in just a few moments dr. deborah birx
will outline the data that we're seeing
around the country we're tracking
literally state-by-state county by
county but as she will describe in a
moment we're actually seeing early
indications of a percent of positive
testing flattening in Arizona and
Florida and Texas governors in each of
those states have taken strong steps to
flatten the curve and again as dr. Burks
will describe we're beginning to see
early indications that positivity is
flattening and in Arizona and Florida we
are beginning to see declining numbers
of emergency room visits as well we
believe that take away from this for
every American particularly in those
states that are impacted is just keep
doing what you're doing because we're
starting to see the first indications
that as we were able to do in the
Northeast as we were able to do
in New Orleans in Louisiana and Michigan
and other places around the country
we're putting into practice those
mitigation efforts and we're beginning
to see indications that they are having
a good effect we are focused on the
states where more than half of the new
cases have arisen Texas Arizona Florida
and California and have received
encouraging reports even through this
morning strong supplies of PPE and
hospitals Hospital capacity remains
strong the one need that we did hear
from governor's across the region is for
personnel and over the last week working
through FEMA the Department of Defense
and HHS we've been processing a request
to deploy over a thousand and 70 doctors
and nurses and medical personnel at this
point roughly 525 doctors and nurses are
on the ground in Arizona California and
Texas and we're processing a request
from Florida for an additional amount
we've made it very clear as as we if
you'll recall we deployed at the
president's Direction active duty
military medical personnel to New York
to New Jersey to Connecticut to Michigan
to Louisiana and we're in the process of
doing that again just to make sure that
that those dedicated doctors and nurses
and health care workers have the relief
that they need as we see cases rising in
various communities across the Sunbelt
and we'll continue to work that we had a
conference call yesterday with the
nation's governor's we are in the
process of continuing to sound every
week a detailed county-by-county
summaries analysis and recommendations
to governor's that are being that are
being implemented and well received
we also are issuing renewed guidance on
preservation and reuse of PPE again what
we're hearing and not just speaking to
governor's but talking directly to
hospitals is that frankly because of the
historic effort the
president Trump implemented to spin up
hundreds of millions of supplies of
gloves and and masks and face shields
and as well as the construction of
ventilators we now have fifty nine
thousand ventilators in our supplies PPE
we here remains very strong but we're
encouraging healthcare workers to begin
now to use some of the best practices
that we learned in other parts of the
country to to preserve and to reuse the
PPE supplies so our focus is to make
sure our states have everything they
need when they need it and we're working
closely with all the governor's to make
that a reality but what brings us to the
Department of Education is as we as we
see to the needs of our state's and we
focus on the health care of the American
people we're working to reopen America
and reopen America schools yesterday
President Trump convened a summit of
education leaders and health officials
at the White House and as the president
made clear yesterday it's time it's time
for us to get our kids back to school
and the summit yesterday gave us an
opportunity to to outline and to learn
what we might be able to do that in just
a few moments I'm going to ask secretary
DeVos to talk about the approach the
Department of Education is taking to
assisting local communities and States
in bringing their schools back online
and also we hear from dr. Bob Redfield
who has been literally since early in
this pandemic providing guidance to
schools and will be issuing additional
guidance next week I wouldn't want to
pass the opportunity though not just as
vice president but as as someone who's
been married to a schoolteacher now for
35 years just to say to say thank you to
all the teachers out there from early in
this pandemic and teachers learned how
to do the distance teaching and did a
remarkable job often times having to
care for their own families and make
sure their own children's studies were
happening so all of our America's
teachers we say thank you we also want
to say thank you to the
the parents who had to step in and
become educators for all of their kids
it's really been remarkable when you see
what our kids have been able to
accomplish during this difficult time
but what we heard again yesterday from
education officials and and what we
heard from the American Academy of
Pediatrics it's absolutely essential
that we get our kids back into classroom
for in-person learning we can't let our
kids fall behind academically but it's
important that the American people
remember that that for children that
that have mental health issues for
special needs children for nutrition for
children in in communities facing
persistent poverty the school is the
place where they receive all those
services and so this is not just simply
about making sure our kids are learning
and they're advancing academically but
but but for their mental health for
their well-being for their physical
health for nutrition we got to get our
kids back to school and as as you heard
the president yesterday and even again
this morning we're absolutely determined
to work in partnership with our states
to give the guidance for states and
communities to be able to safely reopen
our schools the CDC will be issuing new
guidance next week part of a five-part a
series of recommendations that will give
all new tools to our schools but what
dr. Redfield made clear yesterday I'm
sure he'll make clear again today is
we're here to help
we don't want federal guidance to be a
substitute for state and local laws and
rules and guidance we we're here to
assist with the shared objective that I
think is shared by every parent in
America which is we want to get our kids
back I'm going to get them back in the
classroom I want to get our teachers
back in the front of those classrooms we
got to get our kids learning in person
once again
as Congress is still in recess but we'll
gather again soon we already earn
discussions about additional potential
support although we were able to remind
governor's at thirteen point three
billion dollars is available in the
cares Act of four states to be able to
assist them as they roll out and restart
schools across the country at the
present moment we learned yesterday that
only 1.5 percent of those funds has been
drawn down by States and we encouraged
governor's to take advantage of that our
objectives as I said are to save lives
meet the needs of our state's and their
health care workers protect the most
vulnerable and safely reopen America and
safely reopen our schools and the good
news is we are we are reopening America
the jobs report less theirs they spoke
for itself nearly 5 million jobs created
I can tell you evidence all around the
country is that the American people are
finding a way to do their part to put
the health of their neighbors first even
while we all find a way to get back to
work to worship and to school and we all
have a role to play to slow the spread
to protect the most vulnerable and to
safely reopen our country and our
schools and so I would just I would just
close before I turn the podium over to
dr. Burks for her report just simply to
say thank you to the American people
thank you for what you've done so far
thank you for the way you've put the
health and well-being of not just family
members and and friends but but but
strangers people you didn't even know
first and we just encourage you to keep
doing what you're doing keep heating the
guidance of state and local authorities
practice good hygiene wash your hands
wear a mask wherever a state and local
authorities determined it's indicated or
where a mass where you can't engage in
social distancing this is the role each
of us can continue to play and we're
seeing some early indications in some of
the most impacted States that Americans
are doing just that
so we want to encourage you on and tell
you that we're gonna continue to do our
part and I'm just absolutely confident
just as we proved when the
pandemic was striking so deeply in the
Northeast when it was striking in the
Louisiana and in Michigan the American
people know what needs to be done and we
know we can do it and we flattened we
flattened the curve before we slowed the
spread before and we can do it again but
we've got to all do our part and we'll
do it together with that dr. deborah
birx and and then we'll get a report
from Admiral gerard before we move on to
other reports Thank You mr. vice
president if I could have the first
slide please and I I know some of you do
watch what I wear so I'm wearing this
specially today on this came from the
Salt River tribe I just want a mask can
be a fashion statement and I want to
thank the Salt River tribe it was a real
pleasure to be out and speaking to
individuals around the United States
about the issues that they're facing
with Cova 19 to be able to meet with
communities hospital personnel
african-american communities Hispanic
communities and our pride tribal nations
that was a privilege last week I want to
start with Arizona just to pick up where
the Vice President left off that orange
line is the number of tests performed
and the blue line is the test positivity
now this is at the level of the state
and Arizona does have three counties
that we're tracking very closely
obviously you know the largest one being
famous and Maricopa County but this dish
does show that the blue line which is a
five day at seven day average and thank
you to the data team for these wonderful
slides the fight the seven day average
is showing some flattening and they find
that encouraging also equally
encouraging at this point because we
know that the test positivity rate is
the first thing to increase and we're
hoping that it heralds a stability in
Arizona of at least reaching a plateau
and their curve the red line represents
the emergency room visits for any other
kovat like symptoms and this is also an
early indicator and we find that
encouraging the next slide does show the
counties that were tracking obviously
the largest County being Maricopa
with the largest number of infections
but clearly there's issues in Yuma and
Pema the vice president mentioned the
weekly reports that go to governor's
this is what the report looks like a
source there full side pages this is
alaska's on the front page is our
interpretation of what we're seeing
relevant to their epidemic with specific
recommendations related to where we see
them as far as being in a danger zone
they are coded by yellow and red and it
follows that they see everything you're
seeing on that first report and boxes
warning boxes and then each of the
counties are represented so that they
have in one place five pages from the
White House and Task Force it summarizes
what we're seeing and that goes out
weekly next slide please
this looks at Florida and you can see in
the same way the red line early
suggestions of decreasing emergency room
visits for the symptoms of kovat and
some stability starting in that blue
line opening that heralds a stability
and the number of daily reported cases
we also understand that we went through
a holiday weekend and holiday weekends
can impact data's on both end under
reporting through the weekend and then
catch-up reporting Monday Tuesday and
Wednesday after holiday weekend next
slide this shows the counties of Florida
that we are tracking these are the
top-ten counties in Florida and you can
see each of them have a different
profile I want to call your attention to
the counties that are across the bottom
there that are more difficult to see
some of those represent Jacksonville and
our other large metros including Tampa
when the governor talks about how they
were steady and low for a long period of
time after reopening this is where that
is reflected for almost five weeks after
reopening clearly there was something
that happened though and those that
we're looking into across the board
because whatever happened in Florida
happened across the Sunbelt and that all
of the curves and all of the findings
are mirrored if you remember early on in
March and April we were talking about
first the what the new
Metro followed by Boston followed by
Philadelphia than Chicago and New
Orleans was with the New York Metro and
so it was a series of individual curves
in this case whatever occurred occurred
almost simultaneously across the south
and so we're investigating that very
closely to really see the etiology
behind that because that can help us as
an early warning signal but also help us
and guidance to the American people of
what we're asking us to do next slide
Texas and you can see Texas is in a
similar situation with their blue line
and we're watching this very closely
across Texas next slide but I think all
of you know that there's a series of
major metros in Texas with significant
increase in cases from Houston to Dallas
to San Antonio to al Paso and McClellan
area and so the governor's get this type
of report with specific recommendations
and then finally California where you
can see the next slide thank you again a
long time of stability but then this
increase in the number of test positives
and rapid increase in cases next slide
and you can see the majority of the
issue is in the Los Angeles area
although we see this through
Riverside Imperial Sacramento and now
San Francisco with increased number of
cases so I want to finish with where the
Vice President started about the
sacrifices of the American people
because in that recommendations are very
clear recommendations that when you have
a county with these types of cases we
are recommending everyone using a face
covering and I think the studies now
that have been done showing that cotton
face coverings work that does open up
the ability for us all to have
individualized face coverings that
express our personality but in addition
I think the work that these governors
have done too and ask the American
people does it stop going to bars to
close the bars to move to outdoor dining
to decrease endure any kind of indoor
gatherings again to all of the Americans
out there that are in these four states
and the states that have
in the report we're in the red zone
because there's a series of other states
that we have in that zone is really
asking the American people in those
counties and in those states in those
states to not only use the face
coverings not going to bar is not going
to indoor dining but really not
gathering in homes either and decreasing
those gatherings back down to our phase
one recommendation which was ten or less
so thank you thank you mr. sikes
president Thank You mr. vice president
since we're breaking on our face
coverings this was made by a small
religious community in Pennsylvania who
who are helped by the Public Health
Service and they hand sewed these for a
lot of our officers to match our
operational dress those blue uniform so
I wear this proudly and I think of that
community every single day everybody
pitching in across America to help us
all
so in terms of testing when it cover
three quick topics first one is just
where we are numerically vice president
has already said we are now topping 39
million tests across the country the
state's really crushed their goal in
June the state goals was about twelve
point nine million in June CDC numbers
have finalized that at about sixteen and
a half million tests for June so
congratulations to almost all of the
states who made their goal exceeded
their goal we're doing very well right
now
between six and seven hundred thousand
tests per day we did top the 700
thousand mark last week and were
averaging about about six hundred and
twenty six hundred and thirty thousand
tests per day we continue to ship we are
ripe with swabs and media so the states
tell us what they need we work with them
to set those goals based on their state
testing plans after technical assistance
by the CDC in my office
FEMA ships those every week now that's
along with a spur the assistant
secretary for preparedness and response
at HHS so that's sort of the overall
general view we announced yesterday what
we talked about a little bit last week
and that is federal surge sites we
opened these in three communities there
was a list of communities identified
dr. Burks and her team that had certain
characteristics of their infection trend
but also met certain characteristics of
numerical numbers and isolation that
surged testing might have an impact over
a short period of time so our goal in
those communities is to do at least
5,000 tests per day and those are in
Baton Rouge Jacksonville and McAllen the
McAllen in Texas
and we have many other sites that we're
working with again this is a partnership
with the state and local governments to
make that happen they're up and running
and testing in all three sites Baton
Rouge started yesterday the other two
sites start today and we already have
almost 6,500 appointments already made
this morning so that's going very very
well the last thing I want to talk about
is Phoenix and I don't know if we have
the slides for this I get just a little
bit concerned when I hear things in the
news like we're doing nothing for
Phoenix and the federal government
hasn't been doing anything with Phoenix
because that really is not correct and
it undermines a lot of the things that
we're doing I'm going to show you some
slides I didn't make these slides up my
team this was part of a 55 slide deck 55
slide slide deck just on Phoenix where
we understand the demographics the
health disparities the income levels the
racial and ethnic city backgrounds where
the tests are done where the resources
are this is how we really work the
issues so first of all we're in constant
contact with Governor Ducey and his team
his state health officials are
outstanding we not only talk on the
calls but we have frequent calls and I
know dr. Redfield does this as well and
ambassador birx does this as well number
two we provide support according to the
state plans just in the last two months
we've shipped over 500,000 swabs and
media to the state to fulfill their
plans in terms of Phoenix if I can get
the first slide back please I just want
to say that yes we have lots of support
in Phoenix this is the community-based
testing locations I didn't decode this
because it's right out of my slide deck
Phoenix has three federally funded
retail sites this is
on a per capita basis you come up get a
test these sites not these three sites
but this overall program has tested just
under a million individuals and they're
located specifically in communities of
high social vulnerability we have three
there we also have 13 what we call 3.0
sites these are retail pharmacies that
because of our regulatory flexibility
they can do that without a federal
stipend or grant they do this just
through the insurance Medicare and
Medicaid billing system so those are 16
federal sites we have in Phoenix next
slide I don't know if there's a map to
go with that but under the leadership of
secretary azar we've really surged into
FQHCs federally qualified health centers
this is where you really want testing to
happen because these are medical homes
for those who are indigent and
underserved we have 28 FQHC sites
performing testing just in the just in
the Phoenix area right now next slide we
don't have that slide but let me talk
about we've also identified every single
testing machine in Phoenix
so there are testing machines to do tens
of thousands of tests per day and we're
sending at least a hundred thousand okay
maybe it'll come up maybe it won't but
at least a hundred thousand assays to
the Phoenix area every week so these are
all the things we're doing in the
background that that happened on a
regular basis that we do community by
community by community now two days ago
um I heard that mayor Gallego was
unhappy because there was no federal
support I heard that on Monday on Monday
morning I was on the phone with the FEMA
representative in the afternoon it was
clear to me that Phoenix was not in tune
with all the things that the state were
doing we convened a call last night
where we had Governor Ducey's people on
the phone where we had the mayor's
people on the phone where we had various
health officials on the phone we got
everybody together understood where the
gaps are there's a surge from Arizona
State there are search and testing sites
that are state testing sites in Phoenix
that are up there and this morning
governor Ducey looked at everything
thought a surge site would be helpful in
west Phoenix he requested that and we're
contracting that right now
so I just wanted to give you that
example because it really pains me when
somebody says the federal government
isn't doing anything when we have 41
federal sites there we're sending
supplies were sending tests and we work
with the governor every day and if
there's an appropriate request and it's
on the list for dr. Burks which it was
we will send a search site and that's
what we're doing we're contracting that
this afternoon thank you thank you hope
you're wrong as we said the focus today
is unsafely reopening our schools and as
we discussed yesterday at the White
House summit from very early in this
process the Centers for Disease Control
has been issuing guidance for schools
and for child care services in early
March March the 12th to be specific and
when we first published the 15 days to
slow this read and encourage people to
engage in schooling from home wherever
possible from that point forward cdc has
published decision trees about how
schools can begin to develop reopening
plans and just last week published new
guidance for k-12 schools but next week
as dr. Redfield can elaborate in a few
moments they'll be issuing five new
documents that'll range from preparing
communities to return to school safely
to decision making tools for parents and
caregivers and to create symptom
screening considerations as as children
and teachers return to school but as we
made clear yesterday
we'll make clear again today we're here
to help and none of the CDC's
recommendations are intended to replace
state local rules and guidance that what
we've made clear to governors and a
state and local health officials is CDC
stands ready to work with local
officials as they tailor their plan for
reopening their schools but we're all
committed to getting our kids back in
the classroom and getting them back in
the classroom this fall with that I want
the Secretary of Education to reflect on
on the efforts she's making here
the Department of Education that will
hear from dr. Redfield and then a few
wrap-up comments from Secretary of HHS
before we go to questions thank you so
much mr. vice president thanks for
hosting the task force here today we are
so grateful to the President and to you
for your leadership on doing what's
right for students yesterday we had a
really good and important conversation
at the White House with local leaders
and great teachers and parents it was
insightful and inspiring and as mrs.
pence noted these past few months
parents have worn multiple hats they
really are our unsung heroes and I might
add as the vice president noted as are
the teachers who were often playing dual
roles as parents themselves and
continuing to help their students learn
she also said mrs. pence also said that
as we re open businesses restaurants
theaters in our country we simply can't
leave out our schools and that is so
correct students can and must continue
to learn full-time I've been really
inspired by the innovative teachers
schools and their communities that have
kept learning going through this past
few months and they're getting ready to
do it again this fall a couple of great
examples in Harlem and the surrounding
boroughs in New York Success Academy
moved to distance learning in one week
using multiple technology platforms
teachers there insisted on in learning
new materials right along with their
students the students were still graded
they made sure all the students had the
needed tech that they did not maybe have
at home initially miami-dade County used
existing instructional continuity plans
to make a seamless transition to
distance learning
they added interventions for students
who were struggling already before the
pandemic the International Leadership
Academy in Texas started from the
mindset that not learning wasn't an
option for any student they delivered
multilingual and special edgy
Asian curriculum to all of their
students there were a number of schools
and districts across the country that
did an awesome job of transitioning this
spring and there were a lot in which I
and state school leaders were
disappointed in that they didn't figure
out how to continue to serve their
students too many of them just gave up
the Center for reinventing public
education said that only 10 percent
across the board provided any kind of
real curriculum and instruction program
and as I said I've talked to all of the
state school chiefs at least once
most of them more than once and they've
told me that while many of their
districts in their states have done well
through the past several months a number
of them they were very disappointed in
in doing next to nothing and then we see
as we talk about reopening schools there
are some creating false paradigms for
the fall and here right in our
neighborhood the DC area farik fairfax
county which is one of the most well
funded I would call it an elite public
school system in America offered
families a so-called choice for this
fall either 0 days in school for their
students or 2 days and their spring time
attempt at distance learning was a
disaster
but I have to give this as an example
because things like this cannot happen
again in the fall it would fail
America's students and it would fail
taxpayers who pay high taxes for their
education ultimately it's not a matter
of if schools should reopen it's simply
a matter of how they must fully open and
they must be fully operational and how
that happens is best left to education
and community leaders
I really appreciate something that
secretary a czar reiterated yesterday at
the White House it's a Surgeon General's
prescription for health care and I'm
going to repeat it again because it
bears repeating first ask yourself
what's your individual circumstance are
you or is someone in your home
vulnerable second what's going on in
your
community is the virus widespread or is
it isolated and third think about the
kind of school activity that you're
talking that you're thinking about how
to how to accommodate and deal with what
needs to be in place for things to be
successful education leaders need to
examine real data for their own states
and communities and weigh the risks
local leaders in every community need to
ask these questions and consider all the
risks physical health and safety are
factors so is mental health
so is social emotional development and
importantly very importantly so are lost
opportunities for students particularly
the most vulnerable among us and
students with disabilities the American
Academy of Pediatrics noted keeping
schools closed places children and
adolescents at considerable risk of
morbidity and in some cases mortality
the Pediatrics guidance concluded that
everyone should start with a goal of
having students physically present in
school fully open and fully operational
means that students need a full school
year or more and it's expected it will
look different depending on where you
are what's clear is that students and
their families need more options I've
talked a long time about the need to
rethink education and the EDD to expand
education options for all students this
moment really demands action and America
always was and is and always will be a
country of doers we are confident that
with grit and determination and a
measure of grace we can and will do
what's right for all the students our
nation thanks very much
thank you very much mr. vice president
first and foremost I want to make it
very very clear that the guidance that
CDC continues to put out for schools K
through 12 and higher learning is
intentional for a reopening and keeping
our schools open that it's that's its
purpose we recognize that there's a
variety of unique circumstances for
different schools in different school
districts and so we've outlined a number
of strategies that those schools those
administrators can use to accomplish
this goal safely but I might want to
make it very clear that what is not the
intent of CDC's guidelines is to be used
as a rationale to keep schools closed
we're prepared to work with each school
each jurisdiction to help them use the
different strategies that we proposed
that help do this safely so they come up
with the optimal strategy for those
schools I think it's critical and it
would be personally very disappointing
to me and I know my agency if we saw
that individuals were using these
guidelines as a rationale for not
reopening our schools I think there's a
series of different additional
guidelines that we are about to put out
to help really with the K through 12
community particularly at the community
level to help open safely guidelines
also that come out or consideration
documents for parents and caregivers
guidelines for schools to help them
understand how best to do symptom
surveillance and characterize symptoms
in the schools as a tool and guidelines
to really work at how and the ins and
outs of using facemask in the school
setting as well as finally some guidance
in to help the schools
have systems which they can monitor
their programs but I want to close by
just reiterating again the purpose of
CDC's guidances remember it's guidance
it's not requirements and its purpose is
to facilitate the reopening and the
keeping open the schools in this country
because as a as the vice president said
it is critical that we get these schools
open and do it safely we're prepared to
work with all the school districts and
schools to help them facilitate their
development of their own unique plan to
accomplish that thank you thanks doctor
opening up schools is the right thing to
do for our kids so they don't fall
behind academically and also so that
children that are in need of services
special needs children children with
mental health issues nutrition needs
have the support that they receive at
the schools it's important though for
parents and for working families and we
I asked secretary Scalia to be here from
the Department of Labor to speak about
the impact on as we put America back to
work with make it possible for us to
have single parents back in the
workforce it's it's essential that we
get our schools open as well and so I
wanted Secretary Scalia and then of
course Secretary of HHS to finish our
remarks before we go to questions
secretary
Thank You mr. vice president it's good
to be with you all today for reasons
that a secretary devos is mentioned at
the vice president mentioned of course
having our schools open is so important
to our children's education but as the
vice president has said it's very
important as well to working men and
women across the country who need to be
able to structure their work days in a
predictable manner
in the expectation that schools will be
open and their children will be able to
be in school so that the parents in turn
can have a predictable schedule that
they bring to the workplace of course
that's important to our business places
as well and in that sense it's really
critically important to our national
reopening one study has suggested that
if we closed all our schools and daycare
for just a month just hypothetically if
we if we did that the impact on us
productivity would be on the order of 50
billion dollars and gives you some sense
of the impact having our schools closed
can heaven our national recovery I did
want to mention a couple of groups in
particular to whom this is very
important first lower wage workers one
of the great triumphs of the economy
that we have joy until the virus came
was how well lower income men and women
were doing in the workplace we as you
know had unemployment the tide of 50
year low
we had record low unemployment for
african-americans Hispanic Americans and
others and and we had rising wages wages
actually rose about 15% for lower income
men and women during the first three
years of this administration
unfortunately a number of people have
observed this it's the lower income
workers who've been particularly
adversely affected by some of the
shutdowns that we've had in response to
the coronavirus unemployment among the
lower income workers has been a higher
than for other populations and therefore
for them having schools reopen
so that they can themselves have
predictable schedules being able to
return to the workplace is going to be
very important
they hold jobs that are less likely to
be jobs by which you can tell commute I
think many of us know that even
telecommuting there are burdens being
placed on mothers fathers who are
getting up a little bit earlier or
staying up a lot later to get work done
to plan around caring for their children
in the interim but for lower income men
and women that option often it's not
even available and then second let me
comment briefly on working women who
studies show and I think experience many
of us reflects that it's women in the
household who quite often bear the
larger burden when it comes to caring
for children studies show this and and
and again prior to Cove another great
success in the economy we're enjoying
was the employment rate for women the
unemployment rate for women was actually
lower than for men right before the
virus came but unfortunately and this is
a statistic we've been tracking we see
that the unemployment rate for women now
is is higher than it is for men now we
made great progress in June the vice
president mentioned the extraordinary
jobs report we've put seven and a half
million Americans back to work in just
two months and the unemployment wait
rate for women dropped nearly three
percent in June but still we have
important work to do and we know that
working women will have a harder time
getting back to the workplace they
continue to cite childcare at a much
higher rate than men do is a reason that
they're not able to work and so for them
to reopening our schools will be very
important
look just to wrap up in such an
important sense the pace and structure
of our national life is built around the
expectation that our young people will
be in school in in person during the
school year that's so important for them
but it's also vitally important for
their parents and in that sense so
critical to this reopening that is
proceeding very well economically but to
keep going we need our schools open in
the fall
thank you very much well thank you very
much mr. vice-president for your
leadership of the presidents all of
America approach to combating the virus
and for the focus that you're now
putting on getting our kids safely back
to school from HHS's perspective
reopening school safely may be the
single most important thing that we can
do to support healthy families during
this pandemic all decisions about
undertaking activities during covin 19
have to look at risk as a continuum not
a binary question States and school
districts can think about the same
things that we urge individuals to think
about as Secretary DeVos noted our
Surgeon General has come out with his
prescription for health ask yourself
three critical questions where are you
is there significant community
transmission of the virus in your area
whom are we talking about children are
much less much less susceptible to
severe outcomes from the virus than
adults and what activities are we
looking at there are more and less risky
activities for schools like keeping kids
in the same classroom versus changing
classes avoiding large gatherings and
doing activities outside whenever
possible reopening schools comes with
some risk but there are risks to keeping
kids at home too at home kids aren't
benefiting from social stimulation they
may be falling behind and learning they
may be more vulnerable to abuse that
goes unreported by the mandatory
reporters in our school system they may
not be getting special services they may
need they may not be getting the
nutrition that they get at school and it
may be difficult for parents to get back
to work as Secretary Scalia noted this
issue like so many considerations around
safely reopening isn't about health
versus the economy but about health
versus health all of this is why the
American Academy of Pediatrics has
strongly recommended beginning with the
goal of having students physically
present in school
this goal is the right way to use the
extensive guidance that CDC has put out
to help each state and school district
think through a safe reopening last week
we've put out guidance around testing
for K through 12 schools this guidance
like our guidance for colleges and
universities offers recommendations for
how and when students teachers and staff
should be tested while CDC does not make
a recommendation in favor of universal
testing it's a perfectly appropriate
surveillance technique where the
capacity exists and capacity is growing
all the time we've talked with colleges
and universities that are able to use
their research lab capacity with pooling
of multiple samples to test their whole
student bodies and staff frequently
thanks to regulatory flexibility that
CMS and the FDA have provided many of
the leaders we heard from yesterday at
the White House school reopening summit
are doing testing before returning to
school and then Sentinel surveillance on
top of that the measures we recommend
universally like keeping a distance
wearing a face covering in frequent
hand-washing are effective and can be
applied in the college or the K through
12 setting we put out the CDC guidance
to enable and support states and school
districts in reopening safely we want
them to use the tools available to
reduce risk and we'll be putting out
more guidance on how schools can use
each of these tools such as face
coverings on top of that I will
reiterate that our set of tools is
expanding all of the time just yesterday
we signed a new agreement with Regeneron
to provide nearly half a billion dollars
in support for a promising therapeutic
all the way to manufacturing hundreds of
thousands of doses for the American
people
the initial doses pending approval would
be available as soon as the end of this
summer or early fall that is the first
of a number of therapeutic agreements
that we will do under the president's
operation warp-speed initiative
promising therapeutics are already being
administered every day by our heroic
health care workers I want to thank
these heroes who continue to put
themselves at risk caring for those
suffering from the virus we know many
frontline
workers have gotten sick and we know
some have given their lives including
some of my employees in the Indian
Health Service and America is deeply
grateful it is because we are making
progress against the virus and learning
more about it every day that we can talk
about how to bring America's kids and
teachers back to school safely we have
the tools to do it and it has to be a
top priority so thank you to President
Trump and the vice president for putting
such a focus on this very important
aspect of our road to recovery thank you
and the president's call to reopen
schools is there a situation in some
states as a health situation doesn't
allow for this where you would be
supportive of some states continuing
distance learning and we now see the
president threatening to cut off funding
for schools is that a serious threat and
what would that look like well the
principle behind our approach to this
coronavirus pandemic has been to provide
federal support as as states managed
their own response and what I can tell
you is in the weekly reports that we
provide governor's we're down to the
county level in terms of where the new
cases are where the positivity lies and
I think we would account for the fact
that while we hope we hope every school
in America is able to open this fall
there may be some states and local
communities that that given cases or
positivity and that community may adjust
to either a certain set of days or
certain limitations and will be very
respectful of that what the president's
made clear though is that we think it's
absolutely imperative that every state
and territory in this country make make
steps and take steps rather to get kids
back in the classroom to the fullest
extent possible
we really believe that that every state
and has the ability to do that
but for those individual communities
that may be seeing outbreaks we'll work
with them give them the guidance and the
support to be able to implement the
policies that they deem are most
appropriate our mission here is to
safely reopen our schools and as you've
heard from all of these members of our
task force's it's not just about kids
learning and not falling behind
academically it's about all the vital
services that children receive at our
schools it's about working families it's
about opening up America again
and so we'll continue to drive on that
on your second point I would tell you
that at this point I think 90% of
education funding comes from the states
roughly 10% depending on States budgets
come from the federal government and as
we work with Congress on the next round
of state support we're going to be
looking for ways to give States a strong
incentive and encouragement to get kids
back to school please the president
tweeted this morning that he disagrees
with the CDC's very tough and expensive
guidelines for reopening schools do you
also disagree with those guidelines and
are you concerned that you may be
putting the health of students and
teachers at risk
by trying to meet the president's demand
to reopen well the president I spoke
about that this morning and I think what
you will see in the coming days what you
heard from dr. Redfield yesterday at the
summit and again today is very
consistent with the president's
objective and the concerns these raised
we don't want the guidance from CDC to
be a reason why schools don't open we
want to partner with States with local
education officials with governor's with
local health officials to find a way to
meet their needs to open up I think the
president's statement this morning was
simply reflective of the
desire and but we remain very confident
that as we continue to provide resources
we're seeing not just not just K through
12 education I mean all 47 states and
two territories have already published
plans and guidance for reopening their
schools and we reiterated to the
governor's earlier this week and again
at the summit yesterday that we're
really here to partner with them to
achieve that and I think what the
president was saying this morning is
that if there are aspects of the CDC's
recommendations that are prescriptive or
that serve to as a as a barrier to kids
getting back to school we want we want
governors and and local officials and
education leaders to know that we're
here to work with them to support the
measures they're putting into place but
I I I think every American every
American knows that we can safely reopen
our schools and we just want we want we
want to we want as the president said
this morning to make sure that what
we're doing doesn't stand in the way of
doing that go ahead just to follow up
when we're talking about the health of
children though shouldn't the guidance
be tough and should no expense be spared
well I'm gonna ask Bob Redfield to speak
to that and one of the things that we we
have seen and I tell you as a as a
parent as much as your vice president in
the head of this task force I've been
I've been grateful for it is that that
apart from having an underlying health
condition children do not appear to be
susceptible to serious illness from the
coronavirus
dr. Burton speak to that statistically
on a global basis and that's been a
blessing for Americans and American
families and and so as the secretaries
are just said we know that the risk of
serious illness to children is very low
and there are measures we can put into
place to make sure that we don't we
don't see the spread of the virus or
outbreaks in individual schools by
having children learn
single classroom or learn outside as
often as possible not go into larger
settings and this is all the kind of
guidance that the CDC is putting forward
but but I'm gonna let Bob Redfield speak
to that because we we really do believe
that we can open these schools safely
given this the what we've seen in terms
of outcomes among children and and also
the kind of measures that we think we
can put into effect to to prevent the
spread Thank You mr. vice president I
think it's really important to be clear
that our recommendations to open these
schools are really based on the sound
public health and safety and health of
children I think you heard already from
some of the speakers there's substantial
health consequences that we've seen as a
consequence of schools being closed
whether it's access to mental health
services or its access to nutrition
clearly we know a lot and I think it's
important that we don't react
emotionally but we act based on data
clearly the ability of this virus to
cause significant illness in children is
very very very very limited we know of
the post immune inflammatory disease
that you've heard about but it's very
rare but in general this virus does not
cause significant illness and children
secondly and I think it's important
unlike influenza where one of our
biggest concerns is we've been able to
show that it's really schools and
children that become the instrument of
transmission throughout our community
with influenza we really don't have
evidence that children are driving the
transmission cycle of this the most
important thing as we reopen schools and
as I mentioned before we're prepared to
work with every school and every school
district to help them find the right
mixture of strategies for them to do
this safely
our recommendations are not requirements
and they're not meant to be prescriptive
we have lots of different options on how
the schools can put it together well we
do want to reiterate as we reopen
schools is to remember the importance of
protecting the vulnerable that we will
be strong on it's important to limit the
ability of individuals with significant
comorbidities individuals that happen to
be elderly with comorbidities we want to
limit those individuals their
interactions in general society
independent of schools Thanks let me say
just also in response to your question I
would recommend that every American
reviewed the statement issued by the
American Academy of Pediatrics that that
released an important report indicating
that there are real physical and mental
cause for children to be deprived of of
an in classroom setting ranges from
nutrition to children that have special
needs we we heard from dr. McCants Katz
that some 7 million children in America
deal with mental health issues in the
services and the counseling they receive
they received at their schools and so we
want to put the health and well-being of
our kids first and given the fact that
children as dr. Redfield said again do
not appear to be susceptible to serious
outcomes from the coronavirus we want to
put their the totality of their health
and their well-being forward and that
all tells us it tells the president
tells this taskforce that means we need
to get our kids back to school
please particulate it the the problem
the myriad risks that students face if
they stay out of school come to fall but
what's the plan what's the
administration's specific plan in terms
of increased testing contact tracing
increased PPE if it's needed to support
these schools as you well know schools
weren't built for students to socially
distance they were built packing as many
kids as humanly possible which is one of
the reasons why school districts like
Fairfax Virginia
the school
to New York and Texas they had moved to
this hybrid approach some virtual
learning some in-person learning so
what's what's the plan and I have a
question for dr. Burks about kids in
covent if I may well the plan is to
continue to do what we have done from
the very beginning as you heard again
this morning we're we're leav 39 million
tests that have been performed all
across this country
Admiral Gerrard described the
extraordinary commitment in just one
community alone and what we've conveyed
to governor's is whatever support they
need to get kids back to school we're
going to make sure that they have we're
going to make sure that they have the
testing resources we're currently
educating States on the possibility and
working with commercial labs and the
possibility of what's called pooling so
that literally there could be one test
run on say ten samples and and there are
there are particularly universities that
already have built into their plans the
idea of testing all of their students at
the beginning of the academic year and
then doing surveillance testing but
we've made it very clear whether it's
testing whether it's personal protective
equipment or other resources that we
stand ready to provide those resources
to the states and and we reiterated that
once again to the governor's but the
good news is because of the historic
mobilization that President Trump
initiated we literally have hundreds of
millions of supplies of personal
protective equipment 59,000 ventilators
in the strategic national stockpile
testing is scaling all across America
and we know that come to school year
we'll be ready to meet those needs
doctor what's the infection rate among
children and what's the very latest in
terms of that you know in terms of how
the virus presents in children how
children transmit the virus to older
adults nearly a third of teachers across
this country or aged 50 and older and
what's the best practice in terms of
testing children I've never heard of a
case where a school child is tested for
kovin 19 those are all good questions
and I think it really comes to the
evidence base of what do we have as far
as testing and children so if you look
across all of the tests that we've done
and whether we when we have the age the
portion that is then the lowest tested
portion is the under 10 year-olds so
we're putting into place other ways to
get testing results from them and
looking at antibody in that discarded
samples and try to fairly figure this
out because parents have really done an
amazing job of protecting their children
I think Americans have done a great job
in keeping infection rates low in
children I'm in the sheltering time and
keeping infection rates right now in
this new cases originally I think we saw
great protection people with
comorbidities we are worried now that as
cases spread that it's getting to the
older parents and the grandparents and I
call on again every multi-generational
household get tested and protect those
in the household and we do know that
there are children with vulnerabilities
and certainly within the CDC plan and
Department of Education it's protecting
those children also from getting exposed
to the virus because we do know there
are children with comorbidities we know
that their children in America with
cancer and getting undergoing
chemotherapy but when you ask that
question the parents have so protected
their children and remember early on we
said test if you have symptoms and now
we know that if you're under 18 the
majority of you don't have symptoms and
so really figuring out and there's
universities working around the country
on a saliva test so it'd be easy easier
for children to put saliva in a tube
just basically what we call spitting in
a tube are spitting through a straw into
a tube and looking at that kind of
innovation and testing and what Admiral
girar has been working on very hard is
this antigen based testing and getting
that equipment into both vulnerable
areas like nursing homes assisted living
and other places but also considering
how a school district could use that
would make it much easier to test and do
you saliva so all of those are being
worked on and it's why we've been
pushing on the antigen test I know you
heard me talk about that in April we're
pushing on that because we think it is
important
for testing of students and testing and
universities but we have the our data is
skewed originally to people with
symptoms and then skewed to adults over
18 and so we are looking very closely
into that category by using our antibody
test think the vice-president covered
that incredibly well we know that
mortality rate in under twenty five from
the CDC data is less than 0.1% and so
that has been holding but until we know
how many have been infected we have no
evidence that there is significant
mortality in children without coexisting
diseases and that's what we're looking
for right now is to really make sure
we've unter overturned every Rock and
understand that in deep detail we all
know the CDC guidelines are not
requirements they're advice and this the
president when he calls it too tough or
impractical making it easier for
Americans and for school officials to
ignore that advice I I have every
confidence that governors and and state
education officials and local health
officials are gonna implement the
policies that they think are in the best
interest of children and families and I
think the president's sentiment this
morning I think is is shared widely by
the American people and certainly by
members of this task force we we want to
make it very clear that excuse me the
guidance that were issuing is is not to
supplant the laws the rules the
regulation of the decisions at the state
level it's meant to create essentially a
range of options and what we made clear
to governor's on the governor's call
this week specifically was that we are
prepared at the CDC to sit down with
state officials and to work through
their plan and
and be able to advise and and dialogue
with them about about the best way
forward but I I must tell you that in
this role over the last four months I
I've been impressed by governors in both
political parties and health officials
in all of our state's and our
territories with the way they put the
health of their people first and but I
must also say that I have a great sense
talking to governor's and a great sense
this is a some of the American people
want to see happen and governors they're
hearing that they know that and that's
why you have 47 states that have already
issued plans or guidelines and we're
gonna work with them to make those a
reality can you explain why the
president is threaded threatening to cut
funding from schools at a time when
educators are saying they need more so
they can safely reopen Caitlyn first and
foremost it's what you heard from the
president is just a determination to
provide the kind of leadership from the
federal level that says that we're gonna
get our kids back to school because
that's where they belong and and we know
based upon what what our best health
officials tell us that we can do that
and a safe and in a responsible way but
to be clear the the current cares Act
provided thirteen point three billion
dollars to support education efforts in
States in the midst of the pandemic
we're going to work with Congress we
expect there'll be additional support
there but the president is just very
serious for all the reasons that we
discussed today he believes and we
believe it's absolutely essential for
our children's academic development and
and for their social and emotional and
health and nutrition needs to be back in
the classroom and and we're going to
provide the leadership from the federal
level to do that that being said I will
tell you I sense a great desire
among governor's around the country to
find a way forward
and we've made it very clear to them
that we're going to partner with them
providing them with the resources to
impact that and also the supplies local
decision so shouldn't it be up to them
to decide if they can safely reopen and
not the president saying he's going to
pressure them to do so well I look we're
going to respect those unique
communities that may have challenges
that have rising cases or rising
positivity and but I think you look at
the nation as a whole
I think what the President of the United
States has made clear as he thinks as we
reopen America we need to reopen America
schools it's just as the president said
early in this pandemic that he wanted to
get our places of worship back open
again I think what you're seeing
president provide is leadership and what
we're providing from the White House
coronavirus task force is partnership
with the governors and with state health
officials because we just got to get we
got to get our kids back I I have to
tell you the the best expert I know on
this topic is my wife Karen and she
spoke at the summit yesterday very
compellingly about how a lot of our kids
are hurting out there they're struggling
with loneliness with social isolation
the American Academy of Pediatrics spoke
about that a very forceful statement
from pediatricians across the country
that said we got to get our kids back
into school and so what you're what
you're gonna see Caitlyn is the
president's going to continue to provide
leadership I expect as the debate in
Congress goes forward about additional
resources we're going to look to build
in incentives for states to go forward
but president's made it clear and I
think most parents in America would
agree with him that we've got to get our
kids back to school and we got to get
them back into the classroom and we can
do it in a safe in a responsible way
that's okay the guidance that the CDC
has put out it sounds like you think it
is in the best interest of students and
ways to safely reopen schools so far so
are you going to change that guidance
because the president said that he does
not like it well I think I just want to
reiterate we're going to continue to
work with local states and jurisdictions
I think the guidance that we've put out
gives a series of different strategies
for them to consider what is the most
appropriate in their unique situation to
adopt again and I want to come back to
the goal and the goal of this is to get
the schools reopened
I did mention and I want to reiterate
that goal is just not a goal to reopen
schools that's the goal because we
believe that's in the best public health
interest of the students for the reasons
you've heard we will continue to develop
and evolve our guidance to meet the
needs of the schools and the states that
we continue to provide that assistance
to I'm sorry I can't hear your question
the guidance the guidance recommends
that that schools have social distancing
of students six feet apart and that's
why these schools are adopting these
hybrid models is because they don't feel
they can keep school students six feet
apart within their within their building
so I'm just wondering if that particular
part of the guidance is something you're
rethinking or do you support that social
distancing inside schools because that's
where schools I think are having trouble
well the president said today we just
don't want the guidance to be too tough
and that's the reason why next week
CDC is going to be issuing a new set of
tools five different documents that will
be giving even more clarity on the
guidance going forward but we know each
school system you know has unique
capabilities different facilities and
what parents around the country should
know is that
we're here to help we're here to work
with their governors with their local
education officials to get our kids back
to school I mean the truth of the matter
is that as we as we reopen America we've
got a we got to reopen our schools for
the well-being of our kids for their
academic advancement for working
families but also as you've heard again
today before to continue the momentum
that we see in this economy that we saw
last week with nearly 5 million jobs
created and I want to promise the
American people we're going to stay
focused at this task force on saving
lives meeting the needs of our state and
our health care workers on protecting
the vulnerable and reopening America's
economy schools work and worship so
thank you all very much I'll talk to you
in a few days
you
you